Christmas Day 1990 the world sees its
first web browser developed by Sir Tim
berners-lee in Switzerland on a next
computer system and if that weren't
enough this guy also developed the first
web server around the same time there
was just one small problem nobody you
knew what the internet was yet there's
Allison can you explain what internet is
it's a giant computer network made up
made up of started it from its it's it's
a computer billboard but it's line it's
it's several universities everything
joined together right and others can
access it right today we'll be going
back in time to look at the evolution of
JavaScript and how it went from a simple
scripting language famously written in
ten days to a technology that affects
almost every human being on the planet
today if you're new here like and
subscribe because this is part 1 - a
full JavaScript course with a new video
here on YouTube once a week for the
foreseeable future our story starts off
in December of 1991 when Al Gore
invented the internet during my service
in the United States at Congress I took
the initiative and creating the internet
well what he actually did was introduced
the gore bill which provided funding for
the first mainstream browser mosaic it
was developed by Marc Andreessen and
Eric bina at the University of Illinois
and released for UNIX systems in January
1930 and later that year there would be
ports for Macintosh and windows and
mosaic was really the first web browser
to start bringing the Internet to the
mainstream but there is no JavaScript
yet just the DOM or a document object
model which itself wasn't even close to
being standardized yet in 93 after
Andreessen graduated he would move to
California to co-found Netscape and
within just a couple of years the
Netscape Navigator would control around
80% of the browser market share around
this time period Andreessen realized
that browsers needed to become more
dynamic web designers needed some sort
of glue language to make their websites
more interactive so naturally the first
thing they'd turn to is the super trendy
Java programming language from Sun
Microsystems but they quickly decided
that that idea sucked so Plan B was to
recruit this guy named Brendan Eich and
his job was to put the scheme
programming language in the browser but
maintain a syntax that still resembled
Java and he needed to have that done by
yesterday now are you going to go ahead
and have those TPS reports for us
afternoon just ten days later the first
version of JavaScript was born but it
wasn't called JavaScript yet it was
mocha syntactically it was a curly
bracket language like Java or C but
under the hood it already contained many
of the features that we know and love in
modern JavaScript things like
first-class functions dynamic typing and
prototypal inheritance which was
actually inspired by the self
programming language also developed by
Sun Microsystems now writing a perfect
programming language in ten days is
basically impossible and Brendan Eich
knew this very well so what he didn't do
was write a highly specialized language
designed only for browsers of the 90s
instead he wrote a flexible
multi-paradigm language that developers
could use to apply their own language
patterns too but there was still a very
good chance that the language would fail
and there's no way he could have
predicted the extremes developers would
take it to over the next 20 years any
application that can be written in
JavaScript will eventually be written in
JavaScript but let's not get ahead of
ourselves it's not even called
JavaScript yet by September of 95 mocha
was renamed to live script and it was
shipped in the first beta releases of
Netscape Navigator 2.0 but just a few
months later in December they decided to
rename it javascript because that made
it sound like the cool lightweight
cousin to the hottest programming
language of the day javascript started
making an impact on the user experience
from day one
mostly with annoying pop-up windows
there was a company that was becoming
very popular around this time and they
were launching their own browser called
Internet Explorer so naturally they
reverse engineer JavaScript and they're
legal or I mean marketing team gives it
a name of jscript so in 1996 we have two
almost identical languages javascript
and jscript and with the internet
growing rapidly people realized that
there would be a need to standardize
JavaScript so Netscape turned to the
European computer manufacturers
association or ACMA which has served as
a neutral party since 1961 for setting
standards in the IT industry by June of
1997 we had the first version of equi -
6 - or ECMO script as it's commonly
known and this gave browser vendors and
server-side applications a consistent
spec or set of guidelines for
implementing the JavaScript language the
document itself is about 100 pages long
and it looks very similar to modern
JavaScript it's just missing a lot of
things like exception handling with try
catch blocks regular expressions and the
strict equality operator one of the
weird parts of JavaScript and
also one of Brennan dykes biggest
regrets is the way equality works some
of the early web designers to test
JavaScript thought it would be
convenient if a number could equal a
string as they compromise to make the
language more accessible to
non-programmers they went ahead and
implemented this abstract lenient
equality operator but don't worry too
much because in a couple of years we'll
find a way to fix this let's fast
forward to December of 1999 and this was
one of the most interesting years in the
history of tech in general I don't
describe it as a bubble that's just
there's a phenomenon with internet
stocks versus all other stocks that's
been reinstated it started the
valuations will continue to be huge
advice making money something's wrong
and at the same time everybody's getting
ready for the world to end a man-made
calamities so pervasive it threatens not
only the United States but the entire
world the year 2000 computer problem is
without question the most complex most
expensive problem mankind has ever faced
but luckily right before y2k and the
eventual stock market crash
we got xmas crypt version 3 it contained
things like better air handling and also
the strict equality operator to make
equality comparisons a little less weird
so javascript is evolving and
progressing very nicely but things are
about to go south and we won't see
another version of atmosphere published
for another 10 years
just three months later in March of 2000
the tech bubble started to burst the
Nasdaq lost over a trillion dollars in
value in that month alone and
high-profile companies started to fold
but the internet was here to stay and at
this point we have a solid standard for
JavaScript but the company behind this
push Netscape was acquired by AOL a year
prior email instant messages there's no
better way to keep in touch you've got
fan we've spent over 1 billion dollars
to create the world's largest high-speed
network now with 56 K connections are
faster than ever America online so easy
to use no wonder it's number 1 and the
browser's market share is being devoured
by Microsoft Internet Explorer and
Microsoft didn't really care about
playing by the rules of the spec in the
early 2000s ie controlled at least 80%
of the browser market share and
Microsoft just basically went off and
did its own thing and implemented its
own extensions for JavaScript now this
created fragmentation which we still
have to deal with today when supporting
these legacy versions of Internet
Explorer but it would also lead to some
very revolutionary features like Ajax
which allowed JavaScript to be
implemented asynchronously which was a
precursor to modern
single page applications now in the
early 2000s work had started on ECMO
script version 4 and it was going in a
direction that looks a lot more like
modern-day typescript with features like
optional type annotations classes
interfaces and a bunch of other features
designed to use JavaScript at the
enterprise scale but one of the members
on the committee was Douglas Crockford
from Yahoo he created JSON in 2003 and
he was very concerned that the ES for
proposal was becoming very large and out
of control Microsoft actually agreed
with Crockford and ultimately refused to
have any part in the es 4 proposal this
resulted in two different proposals
running at the same time
yes 3.1 and es for version 3.1 was a
much simpler version without major
changes to the language this saga would
continue all the way until 2008 when es
4 was finally scrapped for good but it
did actually find its way into the
market as a language called ActionScript
developed by Adobe as the scripting
language supported by flash and we all
know what happened to Flash
the early to mid-2000s were the dark
ages for JavaScript but it was starting
to emerge into the Renaissance
developers in the mid 2000s were
extremely frustrated trying to build web
applications that ran on all browsers
but we saw a huge leap forward in 2006
with the release of jQuery and this is a
library that deserves a lot more credit
than it gets it's one of the first JS
libraries to have extremely well done
documentation and it empowered
developers to build far more complex and
interactive applications that would work
far more reliably on all browsers so
jQuery was a big deal but we saw another
huge event in 2008 with the release of
Google Chrome and the v8 engine both
were released on September 2nd of 2008
and v8 completely changed the way
javascript was compiled and interpreted
making it a viable option for
high-performance applications both in
the browser and server side less than
one year later in May of 2009
Ryan Dahl would introduce nodejs a
server-side runtime for JavaScript built
on top of v8 that included an event loop
which was a unique concept for the time
and allowed you to write event-driven
and non blocking code and because of
those characteristics nodejs became
known as a great solution for building
real-time web applications that scale
and it also made it possible for
developers to build their entire web
application stack with a single
programming language known commonly as
the JavaScript everywhere paradigm and
around the same time the JavaScript
authorities were finally getting their
stuff together for the next version of
ECMO script the parties were united in
Oslo Norway and decided to take ES 3.1
and make that the starting point for es
5 which was eventually released in
December of 2009 exactly 10 years after
the last official spec from a technical
standpoint es 5 has some very important
features things like JSON support
functional array and object methods
strictmode accessors and many others now
moving on to 2010 we start to see
JavaScript frameworks designed
specifically for single page
applications two of the most popular
were backbone and angularjs both of
which came out in October of 2010 both
of these frameworks were trying to solve
a similar problem but did it in a very
different way backbone was lightweight
and handled Dom updates with an
imperative programming style while
angularjs was a little more
all-inclusive and used a declarative
programming style and the creator of
backbone Jeremy Ashe Kenneth is a legend
of this time period who also created
CoffeeScript and underscore Jas and
speaking of CoffeeScript it's a very
important part of JavaScript history
because it's the first
language that really made transpiling go
mainstream and that gets all the way
back to Brendon Ike's original vision in
1995 to create a programming language
that was malleable and transpilers would
become very important with the next
version of JavaScript es6 aka es 2015
and a ton of new features landed in this
version things like promises let and
Const arrow functions spread syntax D
structuring just to name a few these new
features were a huge leap forward for
JavaScript developers but it's really
difficult for developers to actually use
them because they're not supported in
many legacy browsers and that's why
today we see prolific use of things like
babel and typescript because they can
target any flavor of javascript going
all the way back to es 3 while
developers can still write their code
with modern features now another major
thing going on in 2015 was the rise of
react j/s it took some of the concepts
of angularjs with declarative UI but
improve them with a unidirectional
dataflow immutability and the use of the
virtual DOM and it's really been the
framework that has solidified modern day
declarative UI patterns but there are
many other frameworks out there
competing for the mind share of
developers like angular view and spelt
among many others and around the same
time period we've seen tools to help
manage the complexity of these
heavyweight JavaScript apps things like
roll-up in web pack to bundle
dependencies and things like typescript
and flow to add type systems to our
JavaScript and then you have things like
immutable j/s and rxjs to help you apply
functional patterns to your code and
that's really just the tip of the
iceberg of the modern JavaScript
ecosystem complexity and that brings us
to today the summer of 2019 tc39 or the
committee that's in charge of ACMA
script is on a regular schedule of
updating JavaScript at this point so we
should see ES 2019 fairly soon which
will bring some nice new features to the
language but a far more interesting
development is web assembly which itself
is just a binary format that low-level
languages like C++ can compile to to
deliver high-performance applications to
the web it's not a replacement for
JavaScript but it does represent a whole
new way to build web applications and
will certainly have an influence on the
future of JavaScript but if there's one
thing I've learned over the years it's
to always bet on JavaScript it's a
language that has consistently evolved
from its very first prototype and has a
massive and diverse community unlike any
other programming language I'm going to
go ahead and wrap things up there thanks
for watching and I will talk to you in
the next video
[Music]